[Music]
hey guys another episode of overrated
underrated with me garyvee
[Music]
i'm really really excited about this
show i know it's a show that a lot of
people are enjoying
drock actually we just posted ironically
as we're filming this
the latest episode uh what do we do
scooby-doo is overrated uh
a commercial i liked quite a bit as a
kid but it's just
i really think it's just okay
you love scooby-doo no you seemed very
sad no no
i got my ipad really good idea
it's great ip i just i i don't think
it's as great as people
think this is my overrated
you don't agree do your own overrated
underrated it's my overrated underrated
the price is right underrated
uh uh it's so funny scooby-doo and
price is right were two shows that i
watched heavily in 1981
and learned a lot of english from but i
think the price is right is a very
underrated show and bob barker was
a classic so i'm gonna go with slightly
underrated
shark literary board drakutary boards
are
grossly god i like them a lot but i'm
eating a lot cleaner these days and so
i'm going to go with
underrated i i still think that it's
such a
fun way to eat god just give me a good
charcuterie board with a nice glass of
wine and i'm like
in a good place clubhouse is
wildly wildly underrated because most
people don't know about the app
yet still um and the voice
format i'm very fond of clubhouse the
app just
incredibly fun conversations are going
on
uh it replicates real life like what if
like 20 people got together
eight people seven people got together
at a dinner table and just
shot the [ __ ] and then everybody got to
listen to it i think
it's it makes sense why it's working i
love the audio
platform i love audio as many of you
know
i think clubhouse is underrated because
i think a year from today
of this filming a lot lot more people
will be on it yes
asmr is um is
underrated i think it really brings a
lot of value to people
it really helps people focus and chill
and vibe
i think more people would appreciate it
if they got into the game
yeah you know i think snapchat is
actually underrated right now as you
know drock
i'm about to have a real heavy focus
it's a good opportunity for people to
follow me let's link up uh my slap
slap my my snapchat um
public profile uh i'm about to take it
very serious
snap's made a lot of changes and has
allowed a little bit more of a public
public
uh uh layer and i i'm really excited
about getting deep
into 2021's the year of snapchat for my
personal brand
and i think in general it is underrated
to a lot of businesses and
creators conor mcgregor conor mcgregor
is it's funny i'm i'm gonna
break some news here i am buying conor
mcgregor rookie cards i think i only
have three as of right now but hopefully
by the time the series i'll have seven
or eight because
i know this will now be out i think
conor mcgregor is
pretty damn underrated because i think
ufc
is and mma is underrated in the macro to
begin with and i think
the entire mixed martial arts fighting
scene will have very good 30 40 years
and i think mcgregor
kind of like a sugar ray robinson or a
mcgregor
kind of similar to a rocky marciano i
think
mcgregor's one of those names that 25
years from now is going to be in that
five or six
mount rushmore kind of pop culture names
it's also
very focused on you know his spirits
brand and executing in that world
i i think he's underrated hungarian wine
[Music]
i mean hungarian wine is not even rated
unfortunately uh
i'm dying to know where you guys dug
this up from i'm a big fan of tokai
which is a dessert one from dessert wine
from hungary
tokai's were so famous 200 years ago
hungarians the russian czars would trade
like 50 men
for like six bottles of the best tokai
um
i went to hungary to look at vineyards
15 years ago to possibly start my own
tokai
but as much as i know the wines are
underrated
i almost have to call hungarian wines
rated because
nobody rates them so if even one person
thinks they're good they become
overrated
in essence it's a truly underrated thing
but this is the first thing i can think
of is
like i don't know if you have a new
symbol team like not rated
they're just not rated i mean nobody
outside of hungarian descent
humans thinks about hungarian wine which
is
too bad uh musical theater
i mean i love i love musical theater i i
broadway musical theater um i would say
it is
properly rated because i think you have
heavy broadway enthusiasts
and then a bunch of people who actually
don't know this is probably the first
thing that made me say i wish a lot of
people
would try it i think broadway and
musical theater the same way i think of
oysters
i think people just decide they don't
like it without ever trying it
i think a good musical play is [ __ ]
epic
it's been a little call you know it's
been a minute um
no i no i think i've seen something
since hamilton
um i don't know i'm but a hamilton book
of
jersey boys book of mormon like there's
so many good wicked there's been so many
great ones
uh hamilton no i don't think hamilton's
right
i'm not underrated oh we're going to
hamilton why not
um at this point probably slightly
underrated
18 months ago probably slightly
overrated it's calibrating
um but if you haven't seen it it is i
mean look you know this about me
history's the only class i was good at
and hip hop is something i really
genuine one of the few things i like
so to me that was like here gary here is
your show
and i like you know theater to begin
with probably more than people realize
so
i i think it's underrated uh
right this second because it's out of
the news cycle and and this is what
happens when a classic
but at the same token i feel like it's
gone with the wind i feel like in 39
47 53 years people were talking about
hamilton it's like that was a great
thing it'll be redone in different ways
so pretty amazing
draftkings draftking specifically
is properly rated because it's wildly
respected it's a big stock
it's but it's a it's a beast in that
space sports betting daily fantasy all
that
um i would go with properly rating i
think it gets the
right amount of respect and culture
juice for what it is
netflix netflix is
that's such a funny back to back because
i feel like my brain thinks of them the
same way
i would go with netflix being
i'm gonna go with netflix being slightly
and i mean a hair
overrated because i think hbo max disney
plus
i think you're going to start seeing
more and more streaming life
happening and like god it's so good
though
such a good product
[Music]
it's actually properly rated i think the
only reason i went slightly overrated is
because i didn't want to go back to that
and properly rate it
and give the same basic answer as i did
with draftkings but i really have those
things in the same place
a pencil is overrated
the [ __ ] a pencil
listen i know there's some artists that
they're sketchers like the pencils are
overrated
like you think people are talking about
them
i think they're overrated i don't think
everybody's fired up about a pencil
ready i think reddit is underrated i
think the creativity in reddit is
extraordinary and i think as big as it
is i still think people
uh i think it's underrated animal
i think anime is underrated in america i
don't think it's
underrated everywhere in the world but i
think as an entertainment form
create creative form i think it's
underrated
crushing the fern nolan christopher
nolan
um dark dark knight yeah yeah
yeah no i know who he is um
my actor and actress knowledge is
director there you go my hollywood
knowledge um
i can't answer that like i just
genuinely don't know
[Music]
my favorite director sorry drock
oculus vr oculus br
is underrated i think vr is on the
precipitous i'm about to kind of go into
it
um i have a very funny feeling oculus is
underrated
beyond me beyond meat is
i would argue is underrated it's
wildly delicious i think squidward
[Music]
i haven't watched enough spongebob to
give a proper answer here
i like this episode there's some
curveballs in it for me i'm gonna go
with
i don't know uh the bachelor uh the
bachelor wow what a passion for a lot of
people i'm gonna go with
i'm gonna go with overrated i know it's
extremely big ip
i know it's extremely big time show
i'm just not about that life one a
college football champion in ohio vernon
alabama the ohio state versus alabama
championship game this is going to air
probably after the game
right happens so the matchups
i'm excited about it should be a great
game uh
i've not a really great prediction i
think alabama will probably win but
justin fields went crazy
in his last game so it's such an x
factor um
i think it will i think all sporting
events are doing well
during covid so i'm gonna go with
underrated with the hopes that the game
is
remarkable
i think zionists
as you know i haven't bought a single
zion card
i love zion of what i know about him
from afar
as a kid i really like his game
i think he's he's a tough one for me
i i'm getting over my fear of injuries
for him
i'm gonna go with i'm gonna go with
underrated
i think i think because he's a little
hurt
i or you know historically i think
because jamaram
was so lit i think
that as i sit here right this second
i think he could end up being one like
the best player in the nba in four years
five years and i don't think people have
that take on him right now
even though they did 15 months ago some
feel like you know it's one of those
sneaky ones
some of it because i know this is gonna
be recalled one day and i think it's
more likely that he's a top five nba
player than he's not
so i'm gonna go slightly underrated
little baby
hello baby little baby i think he's very
underrated
i think he's an extremely strong artist
bad money i mean
you guys are gonna have to bring out
people that i don't
know or as well like you know i not
personally i mean i just like you know i
like these artists so i'm gonna go with
underrated
now that bunny you know it's so funny
with both little baby and bad money
they're so big now compared to five
years ago when we were listening
so they're probably more properly rated
for me
they're both underrated wendy's i like
wendy's
i do like weddings big shout out to rob
moose we used to drive
from comm ave in boston to foxwoods
um on a whim we'd playing video games
when we first turned 21
and we'd be like you want to go to
casino yeah and we had roommates la and
tokyo joe that weren't 21 so like let's
go we'd go
and we i mean he had like 80 bucks i had
like 400 bucks
but we would always stop on wendy's on
exit 3
in rhode island before we got into
connecticut uh and have wendy's and we'd
buy like six things it was the
[ __ ] best so for that reason alone
wendy's is underrated
please leave a comment below on where
you most agree and where you most
disagree with me on this episode of
overrated
underrated youtube bachelor what's up
it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you